Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel is in the middle of
filming Deadpool 3 they're using it as a
sort of Spider-Man no way home but for the
classic Fox X-Men in Fantastic Four movies
The Other Fox Marvel movies just in general
including Ben Affleck's Daredevil movie that's
right it seems like Ben Affleck is coming back
as Daredevil bet you did not see that coming to
make as many Daredevil puns as possible so we'll
explain what's going on what he's doing in the
movie if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they're filming
Deadpool 3 right now so we're going to be getting
some footage from the set pretty soon and because
we're in the middle of secret Invasion episodes
we're doing a giveaway for Disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want Ben Affleck's Daredevil
to be doing during the events of Deadpool 3.
I'll name a new giveaway winner during this
video too but you probably spotted the news in
your feeds recently Ben Affleck was spotted on
the set of Deadpool 3 in the report is that he's
coming back to Cameo as his version of Daredevil
in the movie after just doing The Flash movie as
his version of Batman Marvel DC everybody is doing
Multiverse movies like we just got Spider-Man
across the spider verse everybody is doing
Multiverse a lot of the events of Deadpool 3
are adapting part of the Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe story but it's a little bit more
like Deadpool kills the fox Marvel Universe and
when we make all the Spider-Man no way home
references Deadpool 3 is actually intended
to pay homage to all the old Fox Marvel movies
because now Marvel owns the characters again and
they're planning on introducing new versions
of some of the characters and recasting but
not all of them some of the characters so they're
using Deadpool 3 in addition to Avengers 6 Secret
Wars big Multiverse movie obviously to give those
original Fox Marvel actors and their characters a
big send-off I have a something of an overgrown
man piece and that didn't fit into any of the
trousers they initially designed so that was
a problem somewhat embarrassing not for me but
for some of the costumers once we figured out
how to Wrangle that uh it went pretty smoothly
there were even some references to Ben Affleck's
Daredevil in Spider-Man no way home Jon Favreau
and Charlie Cox had a bunch of jokes about Ben
Affleck's Daredevil movie during scenes but they
said they all wound up being deleted scenes and
Alternate takes that just didn't make it into
the final theatrical cut because John Favreau was
the original foggy Nelson to Ben Affleck Daredevil
listen this eyewitness is saying that Casada was
singled out by the Demonic vigilante known as
the Daredevil I don't know why you read that trash
I've been hearing stories about this guy for years
there's got to be something to it yeah yeah you're
gonna need a really good lawyer he said they tried
to work in all kinds of references to him having
a foggy memory during their scenes because we're
in the middle of this core Multiverse phase much
easier for them to now literally bring all those
characters back and literally bring Ben Affleck's
character back he'd only be coming back for a
small part in the movie because the majority of
the movie is meant to be Deadpool and Wolverine
with a bunch of X-Men and Loki characters
Fantastic Four Fox characters all being in it at
various points like Mobius is supposed to be in it
Miss Menace is supposed to be in it so you have so
many of these X-Men characters coming back some of
these Legacy characters you can only put them in
so much of the movie because they've been hyping
up the return of the original X-Men characters so
much more than anyone else or the variants of
them from Another Universe same actor slightly
different but similar versions of the characters
it just feels like the X-Men are going to be way
bigger in the movie than say like Ben Affleck's
Daredevil so don't expect him to have as many
scenes as say like Toby Maguire or Andrew Garfield
did during Spider-Man no way home based on reports
I'm expecting the X-Men characters various ones
not all at the same time but throughout the movie
to get about as much time in the film as the
Sinister Six Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield did
in Spider-Man no way home but on top of all that
there will be Deadpool variants there's supposed
to be multiple variants of Wolverine like it won't
just be one alternate version of the characters
because Deadpool is jumping around two different
timelines as he said at the end of Deadpool 2.
scratch
why is just causing as many incursions as possible
gotta destroy this Multiverse as fast as possible
and even though all the attention on Ben Affleck
recently has been on his time as Batman in The
Flash movie and it being sort of like a big
send-off for the character he did film a scene
for the Aquaman 2 post credit scene but that
might end up hitting The Cutting Room floor
now one of the interesting things about his time
is Daredevil is that Kevin Smith said back when
they used to hang out way more back in the early
2000s the Ben Affleck only took the Daredevil job
like he only did that movie originally because
he thought he'd never never have the opportunity
to play Batman and that's who he really wanted
to play it still would be wildly irresponsible
you could also destroy everything hindsight being
2020 even though there was a lot of drama over
the years like a lot of behind the scenes stuff
that went down he still got to do pretty much
everything that he dreamed that he could possibly
do and even though I like the Charlie Cox version
of Daredevil way better than I like the actual Ben
Affleck version of Daredevil it is awesome to see
him willing to come back and play the character
again and as much fun as people made of that movie
when it came out like it got clowned on hard for
a long time Nostalgia is a hell of a drug so if
he shows up in the movie people will go crazy in
the theater let me know in the comments what you
want him to actually be doing if he does show
up in the movie I would fully expect there to
be some joke that Deadpool has about the other guy
in a red suit and bringing those X-Men characters
back supports a lot of the rumors about the
House of M storyline that they're using for
part of the movie in addition to Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe but in Deadpool 3 the rumor
is that in the alternate universe Professor X
and the X-Men originally wound up siding with
Magneto in the Brotherhood of me mutants instead
of fighting against them during the events of the
first X-Men movie remember during the events of
that movie Magneto was trying to forcibly mutate
a giant portion of the world so the majority of
the population would be mutants and they would
reign supreme over regular humans during the movie
Deadpool supposedly winds up trying to win over
that universe's version of Wolverine played by
Hugh Jackman of course and he'll have a version of
the yellow costume from the comics that also makes
it sound like those other X-Men that are coming
back will wear much more comic book accurate
costumes like the ones from X-Men apocalypse 2.
that would actually be pretty cool It ultimately
it's that Universe the Deadpool winds up causing
the destruction of and Kevin feige also said
that in addition to that just like within the
scope of Marvel phase six Deadpool 3 would be a
big tipping Point with the incursion storyline
leading up to Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars a bunch of universes being destroyed and it
sounds like Deadpool does something so crazy that
it winds up causing a bunch of incursions in tons
of universes get destroyed not just that one and
that'll pay off the Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe part of the storyline that they're also
adapting so it's kind of like they're combining
the Loki storyline with the TVA with a version of
House of M and Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
one of the other big casting announcements you
probably heard about a little while ago isn't
an X-Men character but they just announced
Matthew McFadden who plays Tom on succession
will be playing a TVA agent assigned by Mobius
to follow Deadpool and try unsuccessfully but
he'll try to keep Deadpool from messing up other
timelines sounds like he's going to fail pretty
hard they just had the succession finale too so
this is kind of timely that we talk about his
character I believe his role is going to be sort
of Deadpool's comedic punching bag like a similar
type of role that he plays on succession a hapless
idiot who thinks way too highly of himself that
Deadpool just walks all over Mobius said you're
not allowed to mess with this timeline don't cause
any Nexus events and immediately Deadpool just
completely borks the entire universe the reason
they just announced all the X-Men actors that are
coming back is because they just started filming
so they need the actors to be filmed scenes really
soon a lot of times they won't announce characters
to like right before they use them in scenes but
a lot of the characters have talked about coming
back Halle Berry even posted a picture of her
with a storm haircut it sounds like that was in
preparation for filming her Deadpool 3 scenes they
also just cast the main villain for Deadpool 3 and
it's going to be Emma Corin from the crown who
most of you remember played a version of Diana
Spencer they haven't said which character she's
playing but given the tone and the vibe of the
character she is known for playing the different
types of characters she's played it seems that the
character she'll play will be a little more subtle
as opposed to the tone and the vibe of the way
Ryan Reynolds performs Deadpool's super over the
top character and Hugh Jackman plays Wolverine as
his way more hardcore type of character right now
the leading theories for that villain character
are Typhoid Mary in madcap who are big tedpool
villains but I don't think they're very likely
we're talking about a big Multiverse time Runs Out
lead up to Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty kind of villain
so the leading theories right now are actually
lady death which I think is more likely given
death's role in The Other major Marvel stories
like the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet storyline they
didn't really include the death character
during The Avengers Infinity War Avengers
endgame movies Lady Death is also a huge figure
in Deadpool's past she's the cosmic entity death
she can't really be killed the same way you kill
characters like Thanos she's the personification
of all death in the Multiverse like there's only
one death for the entire Multiverse they tease the
introduction of some of the cosmic entities during
Thor love and thunder the death character was also
featured during that as one of the statues but
you didn't actually see a living version of death
it was meant to be a representation of death not
the actual death character but at least they're
starting to get into that really weird really
high level stuff the other possibility and this
is also a little more likely is that she's playing
a Deadpool variant and she's playing Lady Deadpool
from the comics who has been featured a lot
before like in the Deadpool core she's from
Another Universe her name is Wanda Wilson and all
her villains her adventures are just meant to be
twists on the main version of Deadpool and his
history and when I mentioned the Deadpool core
they could have jokes or references about that
at some point during the movie because this is
meant to be a Multiverse movie and you have this
idea of a bunch of Deadpool variants from across
the Multiverse all forming a team together they're
actually already using that idea during Spider-Man
across the spider-verse with Spider-Man 2099
putting together a Multiverse team of Spider-Man
so let me know in the comments which Deadpool 3
villain do you think Emma Corrin is going to play
real big reminder the secret Invasion episodes
have started in my episode 2 video will post next
week after they release it congratulations Chase
sells seashells you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get your contact
details I don't think the original Rhodey is dead
because we do have the armor Wars movie coming up
and the real Rhodey will be in that but I still
think that the current one that we're seeing
on the show is a scroll everyone click here
for all my secret Invasion episode videos and
click here for my alternate ending and deleted
scenes from The Flash movie with a whole bunch
more Ben Affleck Batman thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!